Transcriber: Nour Alsouri
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
إذا سألت سؤالاً
و قلت لدي التهاب ما الذي تنصحوني بأخذه؟
(مضاد حيوي)
مضادات حيوية
هذه الكلمة التي نعتبرها مجرد نصيحة بسيطة
ويمكن تقديمها لأي شخص يسألنا
سوف تجعلني حين أسمع هذه الكلمة
تجعلني وإياكم السبب بكون طفلة عمرها
تبلغ أحد عشر يوم من الخدج
تعاني من مرض سهل ويمكن
علاجه بدواء متوفر
لكن لا شفاء
لأن و بكل بساطة سبعة وخمسون مضاداً
حيوياً قد فقد فعاليته على علاجها .
هذا الشيء  طبيعي أن يحدث
لأننا نتناول المضادات الحيوية عند اي عرض
و نعامله على أنه عدوى بكتيرية
فنحن نتناول كل هذه المضادات الحيوية
بدون أي داعي
من ناحية اخرى
فنحن نتعامل مع العدوى البكتيرية
على افتراض أنه
أي مضاد حيوي هو مناسب للعدوي التي اصابتنا
وهذا شيء خاطئ
نأخذ جرعات خطائة جداً
حيث أننا  نكمل الكورس يوماً
وآخر نضاعف كورس
ويوما لا نتاول
كل ما ذكرته سابقاً يندرج تحت مسمي
“عشوائية تناول المضادات الحيوية”
و نتيجةً ذلك
نحن ندخل المضاد الحيوي لأجسامنا
لتتعرف عليه البكتيريا و تطور من نفسها
فيفقد المضاد فعاليته.
يفقد فعاليته
و هكذا تتكون :المقاومة البكتيرية
بسبب ما نفعله
سنكون مسؤولين عن وفاة سبعمئة ألف شخص
كل سنة يموتون حول العالم
وإذا استمرينا بطريقة تناولنا
للمضادات الحيوية
فسوف نصل عام ٢٠٥٠
ونحن مسؤولين عن وفاة عشرة ملايين شخصاً
و نفقد المزيد بشكل سنوي .
أنا الصيدلانية لنا يحيى
كنت مثل كثيرٍ من الناس
أعتقدت أني احتاج لثلاث أشياء فقط
لأكون صيدلانية
طاولة أمامي و رفوف ادوية في الخلفية
ومعطف أبيض نظيف .
ولكني أدركت أن الحقيقة خلاف ذلك .
عرفت أنه واجبي هنا كالصيدلانية
أن احمي الناس من طريقة استخدامها
للأدوية بشكل خاطئ
و ان أوضح لهم أضرارها .
صادفت شريحة كبيرة من الناس
يتعاملون مع كل دواء لا يحتاج
لوصفة طبية على أنه آمن
هذا الشيء خرافة
هذا الشيء جعل أم
عند رؤية حساسية بسيطة
و طبيعية حسب عمر ابنها
أن تلجأ لأول مرهم تصادفه
في رف أدوية المنزل
تضعها لطفلها وترى مفعولاً خرافياً
دون ان تعرف مكونات الدواء
و لأجل ماذا يوصف
ولا المدة الصحيحة لوضعه
ولا عدد المرات خلال اليوم .
والنتيجة لذلك تستمر أم بإعطاء ابنها لمدة
ثلاث أشهر مادة الكورتيزون
الذي يجب أن لا تتجاوز مدة استخدامه
سبعة أيام
الكورتيزون عظيم و بسبب فعاليته العظيمة
لا نعطه أكثر من مدة أيام
لكن الاستمرار عليه أدي لهذه النتيجة
هذه النتيجة التي جعلت اطفالاٍ اليوم
نصفهم ب“الدبوبين”
لكن للأسف هم يعانون من أمراض
يعانون من مرض يدعى متلازمة كوشينغ .
هذا المرض الذي هو عبارة عن ارتفاع بالسكري
اضطراب بالغدد و مستوى الضغط
سمنة مفرطه
هشاشة العظام
هل يمكنكم تخيل اني اتكلم عن شخص
في بداية عمره و ليس أحداً مسن؟
كل هذا لم يكن أسوأ شيء .
للأسف هنالك الأسوأ منه .
الأسوأ هي الخرافة التي تتردد على آذاننا
أن كل شيء طبيعي آمن
والأعشاب إذا لم تكن مفيدة فهي ليست ضارة
هذه الأعشاب التي جعلتني أتعرف
على طفل بين الحياة والموت
يبلغ من العمر إحدي عشر عاماً
و الذي يعاني من مرض وراثي،
لذلك كان يتناول ادوية مميعة للدم
و كان ملتزم بالمتابعة و الأدوية
وحالته مستقرة .
حتى اليوم الذي قرأت الأم عن فوائد الزنجبيل
وقررت آن تعطيه ابنها .
وهذا الشيء جعله يدخل بنزيف داخلي حاد .
وتم إنقاذه بآخر اللحظات .
هذه الأعشاب المتواجده في اي بيت
و عند سماع أي شخص يكح
أو أي شخص يعاني من آلام البطن
“إذهبوا بسرعة و أغللوا له نعناع”
“إذهبوا بسرعة و أغللوا له بابونج”
كل ما سبق ذكره و غيرها الكثير عند تحليلها
وجدنا أنها  مليئة بالسموم
هذه السموم منها المعادن الثقيلة كالزئبق
و الزرنيخ والرصاص
نتناولها بكميه تفوق الحد
الذي  تتحمله أجسامنا
تذهب مباشرة للكلى
وتسبب بفقدان وظائف الكلى لكثير
من حالات الفشل الكلوي مجهولة السبب
لأن حياتهم جدا طبيعية .
هذا الشيء تسبب بفقدان وظائف الكلى والفشل
الكلوي للكبار ولأطفال أكثر .
للأسفمشوارنا بموضوع الأعشاب
هو  مشوار جداً طويل
والدليل علي ذلك أنه حتى اليوم و بعام ٢٠٢١
ولازال ٨٠٪ من سكان الكوكب يتعاملون
مع الأعشاب على انها وسيلة علاجية .
وبعد كل هذه سوف نرى أنه.
عند مرض اي أحد من حولنا
لا يخطر على باله إلا ثلاث حلول .
استخدام دواء بطريقة خاطئة “كالأبرة الخلط”
أو اللجوء مباشرة للأعشاب و إيذاء نفسي أكثر
أو “طقطقة حرمل” .
لن أقول لكم ان المشكلة
بالحرمل حتى لا تخافون .
و لكن المشكلة انا على وشك إقبال ٢٠٢٢
ولا تزال خرافة  لطب البديل موجودة
و يوجد خرافة تدعي التقاليد العلاجية
هذه التقاليد العلاجية التي تسمح لنفسها
أن تشخص أطفال
مصابين بأمراض جداً طبيعية الحدوث نسبةً
لأعمارهم كنزلات البرد والمغص
يتشخص على أنه هذا “الطفل محسود” .
وبكون التشخيص غير منطقياً فمن المؤكد
أن طرق العلاج ليست منطقية  على الإطلاق
دعوني أصدمكم ان طريقة العلاج كانت بالتشويه
إما بالكي
أو بتمرير خيوط بجسم الطفل
أو بآذان وغيرها الكثير.
طرق العلاج التي تسمح لمشعوذ أو لدجال
أمام أعين أهل الطفل .
يستخدم شيء يسمى “سقوه” .
عجينة مليئة بالسموم .
عبارة عن سم، بل هي سم خالص .
هذه العجينة تحتوي على زئبق ورصاص وزرنيخ
أظافر إنسان ، بقايا حيوانية
مطحون بعض الأدوية التي تعتبر
سامة للأطفال بهذه الأعمار.
لذلك
عندما يحدث الدجال فتحة  برأس الطفل
ليضع عليها هذه العجينة ويضعها
على فتحة الأنف ويضعها بسقف الفم
و بذلك يكون قد اختار أكثر ثلاث أماكن
توصل السم مباشرة للكلى
حيث تمتص مباشرة بالدم
وبالتالي يصل الطفل للمستشفى
إن وصل لأن الكثير من أهالي
يتحفظون على وصولهم المستشفى
بعد إدراك ما حصل
إن وصلوا من كل ١٠ أطفال نفقد ٧ .
ناهيك عن حالات اليرقان
الليرقان الذي للا يوجد من سمع على الاقل
ان أحد ذويه أو اقاربه أو جيرانه
مرض شائع لان أكثر من ٦٠٪ من الأطفال
يظهر عليهم اليرقان  بكل بساطة
الولادات يولدون مصابين بالأب الصفار .
لكن عند ذكر كونه شائع
فمن المتوقع أننا اليوم
نعي كيفية التعامل معه
لاننا نتعرض له كثيراً
لكن توقعاتي لم تكن  في محلها كالعادة .
هذا اليرقان وبسبب التقاليد العلاجية
و الطب البديل
يجعل الأهالي يقومون بتعليق خرزة صفراء
و ينثرون ثوم حول المريض
ويلبسوه الاأصفر وينثرون العدس .
ويعطوه محلول السكر
الذي يزيد حالته سوء .
ويعرضوه “للنيون” وهو ضوء المنزل
بدل التوجة للمستشفى لنضعه تحت الجهاز
المخصص لتنقية دم الطفل من مسبب اليرقان
ببساطة .
كل ما ذكرته هو جزء بسيط من ما رأيته .
وكل ما رأيته هو جزء أصغر بكثير
من ما يحصل في الواقع .
بالنهايه
وبسبب ذلك تراكمت الأفكار
براسي على مد ثلاث سنوات
بسبب ما رأيت و ما واجهت تحديات عديدة
و الكثير من الكلام المحبط .
دفعني أكثر لتأسيس
“توعية الأخطاء الدوائية“.
أول مؤسسة غير ربحية
تهدف لحماية أرواح
الناس
تهدف لحماية أرواح الناس
من طرق استخدامهم للعلاجات بشكل خاطئ
وتوعيتهم بأضرارها
تغير مفهومي
عندما رأيت اننا لسنا بحاجة
أن نكتشف أدوية جديدة
على قدر حاجنا لمعرفة التعامل الصحيح
مع الأدوية الموجودة .
و أول بدايتي
آردت البحث عن الأخطاء الدوائية
التي تحدث مع فئة الأطفال
و كان على مقدمتها .
مشكلة حساب الجرعات
عشوائية بجرعات الأطفال
هذا شيء  طبعا ليس بعيداً عن واقعنا
كلنا نسمع بموضوع ملعقة ثلاث مرات باليوم
كبير صغير سمين ضعيف .
يجب أن ياخذ هذه الجرعة .
وهذا الشيء دفعني لتطوير برنامج لحساب
جرعات أدوية الأطفال خصيصا
بطريقة آمنه .
حتى نحسن  الصرف الدوائي.
بعدها  أن أضم فئات أشمل
و جمعت أكثر الأخطاء الدوائية شيوعا و خطورة
وأكثرها تكراراً
والتي صدر بها من تحذيرات
من إدارة الغذاء والدواء
هذه الأخطاء
مجموعة بأول لعبة الواح
تدعى “تحذيرات الصندوق الأسود”
كل ما تكلمت عنه سابقاً
أكثر الناس تعتقد أنها حالات فردية
وهنالك من يعتقد آنها مشكلة
تقتصر على مجتمع معين .
آود قول أن ذلك ليس صحيحاً
هذا عبارة عن وباء عالمي
يدعى “وباء المعلومات”
وباء المعلومات
هو الذي يبدأ بمعلومة خاطئة تنتشر
وبعدها يدفع ثمنها شخص
أما أن يصاب بالضرر أو نفقده
وإذا تريد معرفة معنى وباء المعلومات
قومو بقتح هواتفكم
أنظرو للكمية الرسائل و
المنشورات الصحية التي تصلكم
أود أن أقول لكم أنه ٨٢٪ منها خاطئة
بغض النظر عن اللغة التي تصلكم بها .
في النهاية اقول لكم
ليس فقط الطلقة ممكن أن تقتل
ممكن كلمة
أو اعجاب آو مشاركة منشور أو إعادة إرسال
انتبهو
(تصفيق)